We've all felt shy, right? One time or another, most of us have felt awkward or worried in unfamiliar social situations. You might have children who hide behind your legs during an entire birthday party rather than play with the other kids. A 2011 report in the journal Pediatrics found that approximately half of all teenagers consider themselves shy. Shyness isn't a disorder, but it can make life difficult for children and adults. In this episode, we talk with a psychologist who has been helping shy people for more than 35 years. and tells us you can't really take the shyness out of people, but you can manage it, and it might not be as hard as you think.
我们都曾感到害羞，对吧？在某个时候，我们大多数人在陌生的人际交往中都曾感到尴尬或担忧。你可能见过这样的孩子：在整个生日派对期间，他们一直躲在你的腿后面，而不是和其它孩子一起玩。2011年《儿科学》杂志上的一份报告发现，大约有一半的青少年认为自己很害羞。害羞并不是一种失调症，但它确实会给儿童和成人的生活带来困难。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位帮助害羞人群超过35年的心理学家，他告诉我们，你无法真正消除人们的害羞，但你可以掌控它，而且这或许并没有你想象的那么难。
I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Bernardo J. Carducci is a professor of psychology at Indiana University Southeast, where he is the director of the Indiana University Southeast Shyness Research Institute. He is one of the leading experts on shyness and has published numerous books and guides helping children, teens, parents, and other adults understand and manage their shyness. Welcome, Dr. Curtis. Please. Call me Bertie, and thank you for having me here today. This is a real honor.
我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是“心理学谈话”。伯纳多·J·卡杜奇是印第安纳大学东南分校的心理学教授，他同时也是该校印第安纳大学东南分校害羞研究所的所长。他是害羞研究领域的顶尖专家之一，曾出版过大量书籍和指南，帮助儿童、青少年、父母以及其他成年人理解并克服害羞。欢迎您，柯蒂斯博士。请叫我伯蒂，非常感谢今天邀请我来到这里。这真的是莫大的荣幸。
Well, Bernie, first of all, I'm curious, how did you get into researching about shyness? When people find out I know something about shyness, that's the very first question that they asked me. And I tell people that in high school, I was a very, very shy kid. I had virtually no dates in high school. And as I tell people, if you look at my high school annual, it wasn't because I was an unattractive kid. I mean, I was, I think, pretty good looking. I was athletic. I played football and had lots of friends,
好的，伯尼，首先我很好奇，你是怎么开始研究害羞这个课题的？每当人们发现我懂一点关于害羞的知识时，这往往就是他们问我的第一个问题。我告诉大家，我在高中时是一个非常非常害羞的孩子。我在高中几乎没有约会过。正如我告诉大家的，如果你翻看我的高中年鉴，那并不是因为我长得不好看。我的意思是，我认为自己长得还挺清秀的。我很擅长运动，踢过足球，有很多朋友，
went to a neighborhood school, and so I knew everybody. But I just couldn't talk to these girls. And so I read this article on shyness, and I said, my gosh, that's me. And it said some things that what you might try to do to deal with your shyness. And I started doing those things. And then when I got into college, if I had a chance to write a paper or something, and I did it on shyness, and then I started doing some research on shyness. So I tell people, I work on my shyness every day.
在一所社区学校上学，所以我认识每个人。但我就是无法和这些女孩说话。于是我读了一篇关于害羞的文章，然后我说，天哪，这说的就是我。文章提出了一些你可以尝试用来应对害羞的方法。我开始照着那些方法去做。后来上了大学，如果有机会写论文之类的东西，我都会以害羞为主题，接着我便开始做一些关于害羞的研究。所以我总是对大家说，我每天都在克服自己的害羞。
I call myself what I refer to as being a successfully shy person, somebody who tries to understand the nature and the dynamics of their shyness, and work on that every day. You often hear children being labeled as shy. You said you were a shy kid. Many times it's not necessarily considered a positive quality when that label is put on someone. How do you define it? And is it a negative personality trait?
我称自己为一个“成功克服害羞的人”，一个努力理解自己害羞的本质与动态机制，并每天都在为此努力的人。你经常听到人们给孩子们贴上害羞的标签。你说过你曾经是个害羞的孩子。很多时候，当这个标签贴在某人身上时，它并不一定被认为是一种积极的品质。你是如何定义它的？它是一种消极的人格特质吗？
First and foremost, it is not a negative personality trait. It's not a character flaw. It's not a disease. It's simply a description of the individual, how they respond, how they behave. And when I think about shyness, the way I think about shinness is that it involves the characteristic feature of shyness involves excessive self-consciousness and excessive negative critical self-evaluation. We say think about being in front of a mirror. When you look in front of a mirror, I don't care who you are. Most people don't say, oh, my God, how beautiful I am.
首先也是最重要的一点，它绝不是一种消极的人格特质。它不是性格缺陷，也不是一种疾病。它仅仅是对个体的一种描述，描述他们如何反应，如何表现。当我思考害羞时，我所认为的害羞的特征在于，它包含过度的自我意识以及过度的消极批判性自我评估。我们可以想象一下站在镜子前的场景。当你照镜子时，我不管你是谁。大多数人不会说：“哦，天哪，我怎么这么好看。”
The first thing they do when they look into a mirror is they primp. They focus on their hair. They adjust their tie, their color. They focus on their faults because a mirror makes you self-conscious. And when you're self-conscious, you focus on your negative characteristics. So we say, think about shy people as having a mirror held in front of them all day long, particularly in social situations. So that's what shyness, that's what shyness is.
他们照镜子时做的第一件事就是整理仪容。他们关注自己的头发。他们调整领带、衣领。他们专注于自己的缺点，因为镜子会让你产生自我意识。而当你有了自我意识时，你就会关注自己的负面特征。所以我们说，可以把害羞的人想象成一整天都在自己面前举着一面镜子，尤其是在社交场合中。这就是害羞，这就是害羞的本质。
It's negative self-critical evaluation. And it's not a negative characteristic. The problem with shyness is that people, shy people don't understand the nature and the dynamics of their shyness. So their shyness holds them back from their dreams and their goals. What shy people need to do
这是一种消极的自我批判性评估。而且它本身并不是一个消极的特征。害羞的问题在于，人们、也就是害羞的人并不理解他们害羞的本质和动态机制。因此，他们的害羞阻碍了他们去实现梦想和目标。害羞的人需要做的是
is to understand those dynamics of their shyness so that they can control their shyness instead of their shyness controlling them. So that's the real problem with shyness is that it controls you instead of you controlling your shyness. What's the difference between shyness and introversion? You know, why do we need to acknowledge those? Sure, there's a really, really big difference.
理解他们害羞的动态机制，这样他们就能掌控自己的害羞，而不是让害羞掌控他们。所以这才是害羞真正的问题所在——是它在控制你，而不是你在控制你的害羞。害羞和内向有什么区别？你知道，为什么我们需要去认识到这些区别？当然，这两者之间有着非常非常大的区别。
If you think about shyness and introversion, they may look very much the same. So at a party, a social situation, you'll see a shy person and introvert standing against the wall. The big difference is that the introvert prefers to be there. They prefer to be a way slightly withdrawn from social situation, particularly the social stimulation, the loudness. Shy people are standing against that wall because they feel they have to. They don't know what else to do.
如果你思考一下害羞和内向，它们看起来可能会非常相似。所以在派对或社交场合中，你会看到一个害羞的人和一个内向的人背靠着墙站着。最大的区别在于，内向的人更愿意呆在那里。他们更喜欢稍微远离社交场合，尤其是远离社交刺激和喧闹。而害羞的人站在墙边是因为他们觉得不得不这么做。他们不知道还能做些什么。
They don't want to be there. They feel they have to be there. Shy people have more in common with extroversion than they do with introversion. Shy people truly want to be social. They want to be around other people. go to parties, they'll go to clubs, they'll go to bars. The problem is they show up, they don't know what to do, they get frustrated, and they leave. A critical dynamic of shyness is what we call the slow to warm up effect. It takes shy people a little bit longer to warm up. And as a result of
他们其实不想呆在那里，但他们觉得自己必须呆在那里。害羞的人与外向的人有更多共同点，而不是内向的人。害羞的人内心深处非常渴望社交。他们想要和别人在一起，去参加派对，去俱乐部，去酒吧。问题是，当他们到了那里后却不知道该做些什么，然后感到沮丧，最后离开。害羞的一个关键动态机制就是我们所说的“慢热效应”。害羞的人需要更长一点的时间才能热络起来。因此，
that, a big mistake that shy people make. A huge mistake is that if they're going to go to a social function, they think, okay, I'll show up late, party starts at nine, I'll get there at 1030, because there'll be lots of people there. I'll be able to mingle. Nobody will notice me because I can just kind of blend in. That's the worst thing that you can do. You do that because you don't understand the real dynamic. Rather than showing up late, what you should do is you show up early.
害羞的人常犯的一个巨大错误。一个极其严重的错误是，如果他们要去参加一个社交活动，他们会想：“好吧，我晚点去，派对九点开始，我十点半再去，因为那时候人会很多。我能够四处交际。没有人会注意到我，因为我可以融入其中。”这是你能做的最糟糕的事情。你之所以这么做，是因为你不理解真正的动态机制。你应该做的不是迟到，而是早到。
When you show up late, the noise level is already high. So if you're anxious, that's going to make you even more anxious. Plus, if you have difficulty talking to people, if you show up late, people are already mingling together. groups have already started to form, so it's much harder to break into that group. So we say, don't show up late. You show up on time. Show up early.
当你迟到时，噪音水平已经很高了。所以如果你本来就很焦虑，这会让你更加焦虑。另外，如果你本来就不擅长与人交谈，当你迟到时，大家已经都在互相交际了，群体也已经开始形成，所以想要融入那个群体就困难得多了。因此我们说，不要迟到。你应该按时到场，甚至早到。
So when you show up early, the noise level is low, so you can adapt to that noise level as it gets louder. You can meet people one-on-one when they come in. So you introduce yourself, and as other people come in, you introduce these people to others as well. You become the social facility. That's much easier to do. Another tip that we recommend is engage in a quick talk. Talk to lots of different kinds of people for very brief periods of time. The big mistake that shy people make is that they think that when they get into a conversation,
所以当你早到时，噪音水平很低，你就可以随着声音变得嘈杂而逐渐适应这种环境。当人们陆续进来时，你可以和他们进行一对一的交流。你可以做自我介绍，当其他人进来时，你也可以把这些人介绍给其他人。你成了社交的促进者。这要容易得多。我们推荐的另一个小建议是进行快速交谈。与形形色色的人进行非常简短的交谈。害羞的人犯的一个大错误是，他们认为当自己进入一段对话时，
they have to be brilliant, that they have to be witty, that they only get one shot at this. And if they don't have that dynamic opening line, it's over for them. Instead of having that kind of thought, make it a point to talk to lots of different kinds of people for very brief periods. of time. You can always come back to somebody, but when you talk to lots of different people for very brief periods of time, you take the pressure off of yourself. Plus, when you talk to lots of different people for very brief periods of time, you start to be perceived as the kind of person who can talk to lots of different kinds of people, and more importantly, lots of people can talk to you. So people start to notice that, and then they come to you, and you're the person.
他们必须表现得才华横溢，必须妙语连珠，而且他们只有一次机会。如果他们没有说出那句充满活力的开场白，一切就都结束了。与其有这种想法，不如把重点放在与各种不同的人进行非常简短的交谈上。你随时可以再次回到某人身边，但通过与许多不同的人进行非常简短的交谈，你减轻了自己的压力。此外，当你与许多不同的人进行非常简短的交谈时，你开始被视为那种能够与形形色色的人交谈的人，更重要的是，许多人也可以与你交谈。于是人们开始注意到这一点，然后他们会主动来找你，而你成了那个
that people are talking to now. And then when you're at a social function, be the social facilitator. Instead of focusing on yourself, focus on other people. You be the person that introduces others to other people. You become what we call the host to humanity. Minimize your consumption of alcohol.
大家现在都在交谈的对象。然后，当你在参加社交活动时，要做一个社交促进者。不要把注意力集中在自己身上，而是要关注其他人。你要成为那个把别人介绍给其他人的人。你成了我们所说的“人类的主办方”。尽量减少酒精的摄入。
Alcohol, people think, well, they drink, and it's gonna make them more interesting, it's gonna make them more witty. Alcohol's a depressant, so it slows things down, and it makes you think slower. It actually sort of works against you. Plus, when you drink to be social,
人们认为酒精能让他们变得更有趣，能让他们更机智。但酒精是一种镇静剂，所以它会放慢节奏，让你的思维变慢。它实际上有点适得其反。此外，当你为了社交而饮酒时，
the problem is you begin to attribute the success to the alcohol so you feel that the only time you can be likable or the only time you can be social is when you're drinking. And so what generally tends to happen is people have to drink more and more and more. So if you know the kinds of things that you need to do, the kinds of things that we recommend, that you practice these kinds of things, and then you do them and achieve a certain success,
问题在于你开始将成功归功于酒精，所以你会觉得只有在喝酒的时候自己才讨人喜欢，或者只有在喝酒时才能进行社交。因此通常发生的情况是，人们不得不喝得越来越多、越来越多。所以，如果你了解自己需要做的事情，了解我们推荐的那些方法，去练习这些方法，然后去付诸实践并取得一定的成功，
you get to take credit for that social success instead of attributing it to the alcohol, that gives you self-confidence. That gives you a sense of efficacy. And when you begin to start feeling that way, you'll want to be more social. Just like as you play tennis and you get better at tennis, you're going to want to play tennis.
你就可以将社交的成功归功于自己，而不是归功于酒精，这会给你带来自信。这会给你带来效能感。当你开始有这种感觉时，你就会想要进行更多的社交。就像你打网球一样，当你网球打得越来越好时，你就会想要去打网球。
You're going to want to play different people at different levels. The same thing is true with dealing with your shyness. Right. I'm a parent of a young girl. She's five. She's been labeled shy. many times, even when she was a baby. What sort of effect does that have on children?
你会想要和不同水平的人对打。应对害羞也是同样的道理。没错。我是一个小女孩的家长。她五岁了。她多次被贴上害羞的标签，甚至在她还是个婴儿的时候就是这样。这对孩子们有什么影响？
How do parents deal with that? The effect can be how you respond to that. Typically what parents do, they tend to overprotect the child. So they'll intervene in social situations and kind of take over for the child. And when you do that, the child doesn't learn frustration, tolerance. They don't learn how to deal with the particular. situation that they find themselves in. So we say there are lots of things that you can do, and those are things that we've mentioned
父母该如何应对？这种影响取决于你如何做出反应。通常父母的做法是，他们往往会过度保护孩子。因此他们会介入社交场合，有点替孩子包办一切。当你这样做时，孩子就无法学会对挫折的耐受力。他们就无法学会如何处理他们所处的特定情境。所以我们说，有很多事情你可以做，这些也就是我们之前提到过的，
before, is to understand the nature and the dynamics of shyness. First and foremost, we tell parents of shy children, you need to love that child for who that child is. Now how outgoing you want that child to be? Secondly, never ask that child to do anything that you wouldn't be willing to do yourself. Never tell your child, oh, just go up there and talk to that kid. Don't be afraid. Again, we ask parents, would you go up to a total stranger and talk?
那就是理解害羞的本质和动态机制。首先也是最重要的一点，我们告诉害羞孩子的父母，你需要爱那个孩子本来的样子。而不是你想让那个孩子变得多么外向。其次，永远不要要求孩子去做你自己都不愿意做的事情。永远不要对你的孩子说：“哦，快去那边和那个小孩说话。别害怕。”同样，我们问父母：“你会去和一个完全陌生的人说话吗？”
And they said, well, I would never do that. And how can you ask your child to do that? When you do those kinds of things, you trivialize their feelings of shyness. So we say take that into consideration. Also, go to the child's strength. Remind them of their successes in social situations. So if they're going to go to a party, somebody, a birthday party for their first time, say, well, you know, you've been.
他们说：“嗯，我永远不会那样做。”那你怎么能要求你的孩子这么做呢？当你做这些事情时，你是在轻视他们害羞的感受。所以我们说要把这一点考虑进去。此外，要发挥孩子的优势。提醒他们在社交场合中的成功经验。所以如果他们要去参加派对，第一次去参加别人的生日派对，你可以说：“你知道的，你以前
into birthday parties before at Uncle Ralph's house, you know, there we play games, we open presents, we ate cake. Well, you know, we're going to do this at Sally's party next week. We're going to do the same kind of, it's just a different location so you know what to do. There's going to be new kids there, but if you remember when we were on vacation last year, you didn't know kids, but at the end of the vacation, you were playing with these kids. Well, the same thing is going to happen at this party. You're going to start playing with a game. So you've done these kinds of things before so create a sense of similarity with their with their strengths give them time to warm up so if you're going to drop your child off at a at a birthday party make it a point to stay there until she feels
去过拉尔夫叔叔家的生日派对，你知道，在那里我们玩游戏，拆礼物，吃蛋糕。你看，我们下周在莎莉的派对上也要这样做。我们要进行同样性质的活动，只是换了个地方，所以你知道该怎么做。那里会有新孩子，但如果你还记得去年我们去度假时，你也不认识那些孩子，但在度假结束时，你和那些孩子们玩得很开心。同样的，在这个派对上也会发生这样的事。你会开始一起玩游戏。所以你以前做过这些类似的事情”——因此要在他们身上建立一种熟悉感和他们的优势，给他们时间来热络起来。所以如果你打算把孩子送到生日派对上，务必留下来，直到她对环境感到
comfortable with the situation give her a chance to to warm up let her get used to the to the noise and the environment stay around until she can feel comfortable with the different but then walk away don't stand don't stay the whole time but again and let her know that you're going to be back and that she's going to be a fine. Another thing that you can do, too, is engage in what we call the factorial approach. So, again, changing one or two factors at a time.
舒适为止。给她一个热络的机会，让她习惯噪音和环境，留下来直到她对周围感到自在，然后离开。不要一直待到最后，但再次强调，要让她知道你会回来，而且她会没事的。你能做的另一件事是，采用我们所说的“因子分析法”。也就是说，每次只改变一到两个因素。
So if you want your child to be more outgoing, bring a child over to your house where your child feels comfortable. So you have a new friend in a similar environment and do that until they get comfortable with that. And then you change the environment. you have this new friend and then you go to the park. So now it's a new friend and a new situation.
如果你想让你的孩子更外向，可以把另一个孩子带到你家里来，在你的家里你的孩子会感到舒适。这样他们在相似的环境中就有了新朋友，一直这样做，直到他们对此感到适应。然后你再改变环境，带着这个新朋友一起去公园。现在这是一个新朋友和一个新环境。
So they feel comfortable with that. And then what you can do is you can introduce another child into the familiar situation. So don't push things too quickly, give them time to adjust and engage in this factorial approach. That's what we do as adults as well. But again, a problem is because things are easy for us. We expect them to be easy for the child as well. well. So we get impatient. We push. We fail to consider that warm-up effect. So there's many things that that parents can do to help their child be social, deal with frustration tolerance.
所以他们对此感到适应。然后你可以做的是，在一个熟悉的环境中引入另一个孩子。所以不要把事情推得太快，给他们时间去调整并采用这种因子分析法。这也是我们作为成年人通常会做的事情。然而问题在于，因为很多事情对我们来说很容易，我们也期望它们对孩子来说同样容易。所以我们会失去耐心，会去催促，却忽略了那个热络效应。因此，父母可以做很多事情来帮助他们的孩子进行社交，应对挫折耐受力。
We now live in the age of Instagram, Facebook, Snapchat. You know, communication is moving at lightning speed. How do you're talking about warming up, going getting into situations where they feel comfortable, but how do shy people keep up in these situations? First and foremost, what we have to remember always, and it's been this way forever, okay? First and foremost, we have to remember that it takes all kinds of people to make this world work. It takes people who are going to move really, really fast.
我们现在生活在Instagram、Facebook、Snapchat的时代。你知道，信息传播的速度快如闪电。你刚才谈到了热络起来，进入让他们感到舒适的环境，但在这种情况下，害羞的人该如何跟上节奏呢？首先也是最重要的一点，我们必须永远记住——而且情况一直如此——首先也是最重要的一点，我们要记住，世界要运转需要形形色色的人。我们需要行动非常非常快的人，
It's going to take people who are going to move really, really slow, and it's going to take a lot of people in between. So we say it's not necessary that everybody keep up with that same pace, so we tell shy people, find the pace that that's comfortable for you. Go to your strengths. And what's going to happen is as you begin to build on these kinds of things, as you begin to feel more comfortable, you'll pick up the pace that's comfortable for you. I mean, think about driving on the interstate.
我们需要行动非常非常慢的人，还需要介于两者之间的许多人。所以我们说，并非每个人都必须保持完全相同的节奏，我们告诉害羞的人：找到适合你自己的节奏。发挥你的优势。随着你开始在这些方面不断积累，随着你开始感到更加舒适，你会找到适合你自己的节奏。我的意思是，想想在州际公路上开车。
If everybody drove really, really fast, it would be impossible. If everybody drove really slow, it would be impossible. You need all kinds of different drivers to make this work. Some fast, some slow, and a lot in between. and the same is in digital technology. So again, there's no need for everybody to do everything the same way. What we need is diversity. And shy people truly represent that.
如果所有人都开得非常非常快，那将是不可能的。如果所有人都开得很慢，那也将是不可能的。你需要各种不同类型的司机来让交通顺畅运转。有些快，有些慢，还有许多介于两者之间。在数字技术中也是如此。所以同样，没有必要让每个人都以相同的方式做所有事情。我们需要的是多样性。而害羞的人恰恰代表了这一点。
We need shy people to make the world work. I've said that we don't need less shyness. What we need is more shyness because shy people are generally great people. Well, Dr. Carducci, Bernie, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a pleasure. Listen, I want to thank you on behalf of all the shy people. you're going to help by airing this program. Thank you.
我们需要害羞的人来让这个世界运转。我曾说过，我们不需要减少害羞。我们需要的是更多的害羞，因为害羞的人通常都是很棒的人。卡杜奇博士，伯尼，非常感谢你加入我们的节目。这真的是一段愉快的时光。听着，我谨代表所有将因为这期节目的播出而得到帮助的害羞的人，向你表示感谢。谢谢你。
Thanks for listening. To hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。要收听更多节目，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。联合美国心理学会，这里是“心理学谈话”，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。